[Music]
[Music]
the hedonistic imperative
is the name of a manifesto i wrote back
in
1995 uh the humanistic imperative
calls for the use of biotechnology
to phase out the biology of suffering
throughout the living world
to reprogram the biosphere and to
replace the biology of misery and
malaise
with transhuman post-human life based on
gradients of intelligent bliss and
i stress the intelligent bliss because
this isn't the idea
that of uniform euphoria this is the
idea that we can
ratchet up our hedonic range and hedonic
set points with the aid of
genetic engineering so that all of us
can enjoy lifelong gradients of
well-being
[Music]
what will transhuman and post-human life
be like and and yet the sensible answer
i can i can give you is i don't know
but one of the many reasons for
stressing
recalibration is that
by raising hedonic set points it's not
necessary for you
or almost anyone else to sacrifice
their existing values and preferences
crudely it just means that you can wake
up in the morning
feeling in a fantastically good mood
and pursue whatever you consider most
valuable
or worthwhile as now that's a
rather bio-conservative answer in
practice i think
uh mastery of our reward circuitry
intelligence amplification radical life
extension is going to
transform the nature of
of life in ways that uh
far beyond the pleasure pain axis
but yes i regard a precondition of
any civilized society is that we
get rid of uh involuntary
suffering any state below hedonic zero
essentially evolution didn't design us
to be happy other things being equal it
is
good to be discontented a lot of the
time instead of
counting your blessings as philosophers
have urged us to do
essentially being restless wanting more
reproductive opportunities
more wealth more status it's adaptive
uh and so essentially most people
spend at least some of their lives and
tragically in many
cases a lot of their lives extremely
unhappy
and resentful however it is possible
to study today's hedonic
outliers some people yes
they spend their lives essentially below
hedonic zero
uh gradients of misery but at the
opposite extreme
there are a small minority of people
with exceptionally high hedonic set
points
who can live high functioning lives but
essentially
gradients of well-being and the
first step really i would say
is to tweak our genomes and ensure that
future humans and trans humans have
a vastly higher hedonic set point
tweaking our genomes is extremely
problematic
uh so why do it uh because essentially
every child today born is a unique
untested genetic experiment and
if you regard it as ethically
permissible to bring more life and
suffering into the world then i think
you have an
obligation to maximize
the opportunities of your future child
to flourish
and that means loading the genetic dice
now with the advent of the first crispr
babies
essentially in principle all prospective
parents can be offered
access to pre-implantation genetic
screening and counseling and now
within the next few years in principle
the opportunity to choose everything
from pain thresholds of their
of their future children uh there's a
single master gene that seems to act as
the kind of the volume knob for pain the
scn9a gene
and this is more complicated the
opportunity to choose benign
alleles and allelic variations uh
that essentially set the approximate
hedonic
set point of your future child recall
the hedonic set point is the kind of uh
set of negative feedback mechanisms in
the central nervous system that
stop most of us being very happy or very
sad
for long and what we want to do
ethically i think is to ratchet up
hedonic range and hedonic set points
but you ask about problems yes
countless problems essentially today we
conduct
uh genetic experiments and we are going
to continue to do so
uh i mean personally i as a
so-called soft anti-natalist i'm not at
all convinced that it's ethically
permissible to bring more
involuntary life and suffering into the
world but the future belongs to
fanatical life lovers
uh and whereas anti-natalism is an
evolutionary an evolutionary
dead end the idea of
phasing out the biology of suffering and
replacing it by
information sensitive gradients of bliss
can
unite everything from negative
utilitarians and buddhists to
classical utilitarians and life lovers
of any of any kind
i think it's potentially a winning
strategy
i mean after all the world health
organization and its founding
constitution of 1990 sorry of 19
1948 actually defines health
as complete physical mental
social well-being now that's an
extraordinarily
uh ambitious definition probably no one
alive today
has enjoyed health by that definition
but we can aim for something
a little less ambitious which is
information sensitive gradients of
well-being
but to achieve this world health
organization
conception of anything like this
conception of health
we're going to have to uh get to yeah
the genetic root of the problem
and i'm probably sounding like a rather
crude genetic
determinist i'm not essentially a twin
track approach
is is is is needed to the problem of
suffering
get rid of getting rid of all kinds of
social ills
scrapping factory farming slaughter
slaughterhouses
uh going on to actually reprogram
nature and the rest of the living world
but uh
yeah essentially if we're not to be
having this discussion in
uh 100 500 or even five thousand years
time we're gonna have to tackle the
biological genetic root of the problem
which is essentially that
mother nature uh didn't design us to be
happy
well uh but biotechnology gives us the
tools for the job
[Music]
someone with a very low hedonic set
point
depressive uh is likely to remain uh
depressive uh if they contract terminal
uh cancer unless they're uh given
euphoria drugs and morphine and so forth
whereas someone who
is temperamentally happy a high hedonic
set point
uh may well cope with the challenges of
even something terrible like
cancer far better
but the question i'd say is just yeah
imagine we were to encounter an
advanced civilization that had
phased out disease pain
in suffering and essentially they did
leave the
lead lives based on gradients of
intelligent bliss
would we urge them to revert to the kind
of ancestral
horrors of pain depression
jealousy discontent all the kind of
the nastiness that is endemic to
darwinian life
i think they would probably regard
anyone who is urging this as in the grip
of a depressive psychosis and
candidly i think they'll be right
[Music]
well clearly the idea of a world without
suffering is is ancient there's a kind
of religious or utopian
dream it's been central to the whole
buddhist
tradition gautama buddha i teach one
thing
suffering at the end of end of suffering
um but what's really changed
is the technical tools to turn
utopian dreaming into a
practical practical reality um
and yeah i mean i was very struck
as a teenager by wireheading
this is the idea that intracranial
self-stimulation of the reward centers
shows no tolerance and this
unlike most people but this actually
struck me as actually wonderful
life without pain i was a
depressive melancholy child who brooded
on the nature of suffering
and the awfulness of life but this
seemed to offer hope
but of course most people if you know
the first time they come across this
idea of
of wireheading they recoil at the
prospect
and in order to be practically
sociologically credible or needs to
sketch out a scenario
in which it's possible to preserve
intelligence critical insight social
responsibility
personal development and so
yes just thinking reading about
yeah kind of genetic engineering
nanotechnology
um the final piece of the jigsaw to me
as far as i was concerned actually came
after i've written
the hedonistic comparative much more
recently the advent of
uh gene drive synthetic gene drives that
so it's actually going to be possible to
essentially push benign genes
across entire species even if naively
they carry a fitness cost to the
individual
but um yeah the core essentially the
core
idea of hedonistic comparative uh
ice which i had quite a quite an early
age yeah essentially the idea
of replacing uh the biology of pleasure
and pain
with the biology of gradients of
of well-being um now
uh yeah how far do we go you know
the full-blown hedonistic imperative i
suspect uh yes our post-human
descendants
will actually enjoy life that is if
today it's
let's say crudely schematically minus 10
to 0 to plus 10 uh eventually
civilization might take place on a plane
of plus 72
to plus 100 but this is much more
speculative
and much further into the uh the future
um but uh for now i think uh yeah our
overriding priority is to get rid of
these
these sub-zero states and uh the first
step for humans at any rate
is going to be universal access to
pre-implantation
genetic screening and counselling uh in
the case of
non-human animals before even thinking
of
reprogramming the rest of the biosphere
uh i think we need to
scrap factory farms and slaughter houses
which are
a disgrace to our civilization uh
pigs for example as sentient and sapient
as
as human toddlers it's not a case of
genetically
tweaking uh pigs uh essentially it's
just it's to stop
stop harming them um so uh
yeah i mean the technical details are
daunting but what
daunts me more than anything else are
the political and sociological
obstacles and though at least in
principle i could sketch you out a kind
of
100-year plan to defeat suffering in
line with the
w.h.o constitution in practice i suspect
several hundred years
of of pain and misery still lead ahead i
still lie ahead but i hope i'm wrong
[Music]
essentially it's just status quo
bias um that's not the whole story
and if sooner or later someone is
probably going to say
well isn't this eugenics or
isn't this brave new world um
but uh yeah needless to say the you know
the purpose of you know nazi race
hygiene policy and eugenics was not to
create the well-being of all
uh of all sentients and
brave new world uh not nearly as bad as
as national socialism some people uh
recoil at the idea
of of of soma and the idea that if we
were
all happy we would become essentially
just
dupes of the ruling elite but just to
tackle that's
a particular uh
objection um it's interesting today that
uh that's subordinate behavior is not
associated with
with happiness it's associated with
with with depression and low mood and
other things being
equal if you ratchet up people's hedonic
set points they're more likely to be
active citizens
um but this is yeah a case that needs to
be made
uh if people you know the first time
they stumble across the idea
you know if one comes across an idea or
wants to shoehorn it into existing
stereotypes
and i think many people are likely to
say eugenics
or brave new world
oh there's a lot to unpack there um
in the case of meaning uh other things
being equal
the happiest people uh tend to find life
most meaningful no one says i feel
blissfully happy but my life feels empty
and meaningless
sadly it's people who are depre
depressive experience low mood who tend
to feel life
empty and in the more extreme cases of
depression
this shades into nihilistic despair
and so rather than there being some kind
of contrast
between a life of happiness and a life
of meaning
if we ratchet up our hedonic range and
hedonic set points
life is likely to become super
meaningful
yes it is true that out of the depths of
despair
have come works of great art and
literature but
we have grounds for thinking that with
the use of biotechnology
it's going to be possible to isolate the
molecular signature
of aesthetic experience of the sublime
and beautiful and ratchet this up
too so it may well be that trans humans
and post-humans will be able to
experience a backdrop of superhuman
beauty
every day of their lives and what passes
for
artistic achievement today may seem as
as trivial and banal as painting by
numbers
[Music]
two things i'd say one uh technical
uh one more sociological
uh a new uh opioid receptor has been
or dual function receptor has been
discovered
in the brain uh that promises
uh essentially hedonic
uplift its paths it seems to be part of
the
the negative feedback mechanisms in the
brain
that stop most of us being happy most of
the time
um we all know uh exogenous opioids
have countless problems but if it were
possible
that your native endogenous opioid
function
were richer in theory at any rate
with the help of this receptor if one
blocks it
and a drug has been experimentally
devised
that does block it this actually
promises
in theory hedonic uplift for everyone
counts as pitfalls to consider
i probably shouldn't have introduced it
right right now but this is actually an
exciting development for the future
of mental health and the treatment of
chronic pain conditions
but what i would really look forward to
uh is some
big name charismatic billionaire perhaps
uh elon musk to say
let's use biotechnology to get real
suffering throughout the living world
because after all we live in a fame
based
culture and uh is
essentially if some big-name charismatic
uh figure
you know kind of an elon musk says
something like this the media takes
notice
um neurolink of course has been in the
news
almost as a as as a throwaway elon musk
uh mentioned how it should be possible
to use
uh neuralink to eradicate uh
pain and depression and it's not his
primary focus
but it would be wonderful if there could
be
some kind of sociological sociological
breakthrough
because the technical preconditions
are now in place for a world a world
without suffering
with recognizable extensions of existing
technologies but it's gonna take uh
yeah uh not merely a technical
revolution but a socio-political
revolution too for more debates talks
and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas
at iai tv
you